do one live hey everybody welcome to
Monday we are so excited today because
something very very special is happening
we are getting a sneak peek of the new
Mad Max it's gonna be crazy with me here
is Daniel McGuffey from the word
brothers product development team he's
gonna take us through the insane
adventures we have in the wasteland here
I've been playing this game since 9:00
o'clock my head is full of bees it's
full of death and fire and blood in the
best way possible so hey chick drummer
how's it going PR wins a severe bot I
don't know if I said that right jacket
man yeah there we go yeah look at your
stress yeah we're gonna be I'm wearing
my American dirtbag shirt because I feel
like this is the closest I have to
wasteland where yeah you know I'm
wearing my American flag shoes there
look at this think that's pretty cool I
think me and Max share a lot of
similarities don't you think yeah zero
somewhere no that's not true at all I'm
a cartoon
all right so Daniel take us through this
game first of all we're gonna start with
the upgrades in that stuff there's all
this insane stuff you can do here so the
cars are very important the wasteland
right yeah yeah definitely this is a
really good place to start so you're
looking at the customization screen for
the magnum opus right now and the man
what yeah what's the magnum opus okay
the magnum opus you know in open-world
games typically taking vehicles and
making them your own is a big facet of
gameplay yes and we wanted to put a lot
of emphasis on Max's car and making it
your own and keeping it with you
throughout the entire journey so you can
take any vehicle that you come across in
the wasteland from any enemy okay add it
to your collection awesome but there's a
huge emphasis on the magnum opus and
custom you can see all the different
things you can customize and none of
your right yeah so this is basically
like our car is like our most important
weapon because Mad Max is all about car
combat that's a that's absolutely right
I mean so this is basically we're
driving a giant gun basically kind of a
huge weapon that we get to customize and
all these insane ways it's a mobile
fortress I'm normal fortunate absolutely
and and you're not alone what we'll see
when you get into gameplay that you've
got jumbo
get your he's your mechanic yes yes he's
your companion and he'll he'll follow
you around in the game but he's also
your mechanic that can upgrade all the
different things we're looking at right
now so we're looking at armor we're
looking at engine suspension boost
nitrous yeah bikes spikes are a huge
part of the wasteland so over here on
the on the right I'm seeing these are
all of our it's kind of covered up by us
but we're fine over our stats and then
we're gonna add some stuff dudes let's
add and so our currency in this world is
what scrap metal scrap metal perfect
perfect hard to fit into the wallet but
still much more useful than dollar bills
spins just as nicely me so let's let's
like let's hook up our ramming grill
what do you think about that let's do it
I feel like I'm gonna be ramming a lot
of people you're gonna be doing a lot of
my style it's getting close you know
this like I like to punch people with
the fists of my car exactly all right so
uh yeah we got the brawler to of bump
bars which we do here I think you just
created a new slogan for the game watch
people with the fists of your car yeah
exactly
what so I'm full of fury and I need to
hit people so what should we do here
this one so a couple of them are locked
and there's there's all kinds of things
gating okay those things in the
progression but you've got one that you
can upgrade to the one that's gray and
them in the kind of in the middle right
there alright here we go
somebody just asked are there any
spinners look - this isn't about style
all right but you know what we will make
our car we can make our car pink right
we actually yeah we can make a pink
sometimes it's been over function but
you know functions a huge a huge part of
the game gotta look good baby in the
wasteland you never know what kind of
honey's you're gonna come across gotta
look good they'll probably be ridden
with this radiation sickness but still
you know worth luck you know you know a
wins a win
beggars can't be choosers in the
wasteland oh and we're all beggars in
the wasteland alright here we go
so you just upgraded your uh what did
you upgrade your I the ramming grille
now I got a big old bumpers I like to
call the knuckles yes thing right here
that's it that's the fist of your car
the exact people it's gonna be great I
can't wait so more is not necessarily
always more what do you mean what okay
so your staff please explain all your
stats on the right and you're about to
upgrade your tight you're looking at
tires right now and that's gonna
increase handling which you noticed you
know you've got a deficit of handling or
I do also I got a deficit of handling up
here cuz I'm not a good driver
man can I upgrade this how do I upgrade
my brain not in the game but he's just
like yeah anyway you're crazy okay well
okay so if you push the square button
this is something I want to talk about
real quick
these are your angels all right and you
can yeah you can scroll through all the
different Archangel builds so these look
like prefab things that I can just pick
on right I think so like this one would
be good in case I'm worried about people
jumping on my hood then I've got giant
spikes in my head for sure this is that
one's actually pretty well rounded if
you look through these cars there's a
speed demon as you can guess by the name
yeah that one is particularly fast yeah
so these are kill box I think I dated a
girl named kilvo Oh Jared I think we all
do is a great boss this is like exhibits
dream like you can pimp pimp every
single ride in here I heard you like the
righteousness I had some spikes on your
spine yeah celestial bones that's the
new thirty Seconds to Mars album so
let's go bones pinky finger whoo I love
it
so as you can see as you can see on the
right if you look at the stats yeah some
of these are geared more towards killing
and others are geared more towards
driving perfect and these are these are
built so that we can give players a
taste of these are blueprints
essentially got it got a frames to which
of which we can add on to some some
events in the game are gonna require
better handling more speed Schendel said
I want to see something called gameplay
all right fine all right I get it okay
we're just trying to show you got some
cool stuff here we go we'll get a couple
more upgrades going and then put the
side burner Sonic's I want to be able to
light people out yeah yeah perfect that
that's a perfect example of something we
want to upgrade all right now let's just
get let's get in the car and drive
around shall we car and drivers max look
at this guy look it's badass right here
I always say though here's what I'll say
about I love the movie I love all
wasteland stuff but then he must smell
terrible
we must just like all that leather and
yet you know what I'll tell you what
i'ma did in the wasteland fuel ok the
mixin is scrap metal got it is why it's
like current and Gold Bond
go [ __ ] that's another precious resource
exactly so this is crate this game looks
beautiful now on I hurt now so Chum
Bucket is so tell me a little bit about
this story whose Chum Bucket in the back
why is there a dude on the back of my
car why is there a dude in the back of
your car question my uber driver asking
exactly cuz I didn't I didn't phone him
I just jumped in the back of a car Chum
Bucket is a mechanic you meet at the
beginning of the game as you can imagine
in Mad Max mechanic is a pretty sacred
yeah
pretty Hollow to occupation so Chum
Bucket is who we meet and when Max meets
Chum Bucket Max is fresh fresh off of
losing his his whip okay so he relies on
Chum Bucket to acquire this new whip the
magnum opus got it and Chum is his uh
jump thinks that Max is sent from heaven
he calls him st. boom and thinks he is
an angel sent to help chum bucket Angel
of Death Angel of Death that is here to
help chum bucket survive in the
wasteland that's awesome so he's so
anytime basically we get our car screwed
up Chum buckets gonna help us out
yeah here I've got the harpoon to watch
I'm gonna try to get this guy how do I
let's shoot him with the harpoon yeah
let's drag him around come on buddy
here boy here boy let's take it for a
walk let's take it bro oh I just hit
something right in the jugular
now one thing I do love about this guy's
plant I've been playing it again since
9:00 this morning which is fantastic OOP
lusts we can pull and watch it yeah
there we go
and then you drove over now man you know
that's a I like to just drive over
people at the end vicious combo exactly
hey expired team we love you too
one thing that um I would be told of
this game is the dynamic combat so it's
it's different every time you fight
somebody and tell us a little about the
physics engine because we just saw a guy
fly by and it looked amazing
yeah physics are a huge part of Mad Max
I mean with it with the current
generation of consoles you can amp up
how much you're getting out of the
processors and and yeah and one way the
Avalanche does that first of all in
their world if it's if you see it you
can go there they're worlds are college
and Avalanche is really known for that
yeah this map is insane look at this
giant map and yes this is like we
haven't even unlock this stuff yet you
still have half of
world to drive to and you can see it
like zoomin yeah all those different
objectives you have it's crazy so I'm
gonna do one of the things that tell us
about the convoy so what let's let's go
to try attack a convoy so so the this
right here this red yeah we should say
also this is where we are we're about 40
hours into this game is that we are I
think you've got yeah you probably would
say 20 Jen you're not well you know I
five minutes okay
we just started the same well I think
you're probably like mmm not even
halfway through not even halfway through
so all these icons are crazy so these
are all scavenging locations where you
can find loot and scrap metal right
you're looking at scavenging locations
you see convoys on the map some of your
bigger set pieces are outlined on the
map so those are those are big places
that you can go to and then there's like
- for instance whose gut guess - is uh I
wouldn't say a lie okay but he needs
something from max max needs something
from him got it
guhh cache is a stronghold leader and
okay and you'll meet several stronghold
leaders throughout the game that have
different requests from Max and in
exchange for doing missions for
stronghold leader yes they're gonna
reward max with scrap and different
unlocks for the magnum opus that's
awesome so so here we go so great white
is basically like an empty sea right and
I came across some whale bones earlier
which was pretty cool
and then this is kind of like where oil
was refined and then it all went to gas
town and this is where the big bad guy
is up there so we're trying to kind of
head upwards we're trying to make our
way to gas town we know that we need to
get there ultimately max so what max
really wants is he wants to get out he
wants to cross the dome we all know we
all the plains of silence plains of
silence because we don't know why he
wants to cross the plains of silence we
assume that he wants to escape the
madness in his head and he thinks that
what one would think what I think we're
all trying to escape the madness in our
head and we all are
knocking some of us some of us have
different methods and others max wants a
v8 engine that's that's his key so
that's what we're trying to do is
basically upgrade the magnum opus to the
point where we can leave make it yeah
make it a mean enough machine that we
can GTFO is what we're trying to do here
man it and another cool thing
tell us about these environmental things
in here so there's not there's no real
arrow to go how do I know if there's a
convoy near things like that
oh yeah that's so that's I'm glad you
I'm glad you're asking that
environmental cues are a huge part of
the you can see birds flying around over
there yes so what does that mean there's
food over there there's food over there
so so food food is really scarce Max is
a tough dude but he's also he's pretty
vulnerable yeah you know the leather
jacket leather pants only give him so
much protection yeah who doesn't eat
carbs but he needs his protein you know
and he has it and he can get protein by
finding dog food okay
or little roadkill perfect or I need to
get on that roadkill dog food diet
that's the new Hollywood trend yeah man
or maggots Oh perfect you can eat
maggots good for the colon yeah man I
mean all kinds of health benefits it
comes from the earth it's natural it's
good stuff that's part of the I assume
that is paleo yeah maggots I think been
to the Paleo diet exactly
max is a pretty lean diet but Lulla fun
he's a tough dude but also a hungry deer
hungry deadly oh but the environmental
cues we don't spoon feed the player
anything we're not gonna bombard you
with talk Jesus let's hit him let's hit
him yeah there's some of that physics
based combat right there oh yeah all
right let's get him let's get it let's
use our harpoon and harpoon Massoud whoo
I think you punched him with fury before
you had a chance so over here on the
right you can see where we're gonna use
our flame there we go flame them up boom
I wish I had this on the 101 this
morning ooh what happened there just
when we discovered a new place
look chicken that guy so you were using
your flame pipes fuel fuel you want to
monitor your consumption of because just
driving around Oh tell me how to live
yeah you're right all right free fuel
scarce I shouldn't be using my fuel
pipes like global warming dawg yeah
you're right you're right yeah look at
what it's done all right wait a second
all right so right now I'm looking for a
convoy because convoys apparently you
get a lot of loot when you destroy a
convoy well actually wait tell us about
lowering the threat level of each dome
well so
zone is what divides territories and I
think okay so this is a these tire
tracks right here are actually how you
identify a convoy and if you follow
these around you're gonna be able to
locate the convoy driver eventually or
you can find like a high vantage point
look for a big dust cloud and that's
gonna mean that there's a convoy oh
that's cool
tearing her ass around the wasteland
you're gonna be able to identify them
that way oh wow so we shall we should
kind of be looking for a dust cut just
like in real life if we were hunting a
real convoy we'd be looking for a dust
bunny yeah I mean when you're kind of
dropped into the wasteland you're not
really given a big blinking arrow
telling you where to go yeah you're not
given a ton of HUD or UI right away to
determine it's like there's a dust cloud
over there
well that's smoke so something's going
on over there
oh wait is that a dust cloud might be
bro that might be what we're looking for
all that weight it's kind of far away I
just want to kill that's oh wait here's
the dust cloud gotta go here we go
this game is gorgeous by the way so I'm
gonna tell you what you're headed in
this dust cloud for and you just located
him there we go
so a convoy leader protected by a war
party you're going to want to take out
his war party so you can claw your way
to the front of the convoy and take out
the the convoy leader up ahead oh Jesus
guys gonna get out oh man you doing I'm
gonna shoot it here we go Oh get off my
I think you got him though dragon man
this is pretty brutal all right here we
go
so a number of ways you can take this
dude out you can you can random like
yeah you do never my sides real side Ram
I don't need to tell you how to take
this guy out you got it sit still tell
me though well okay so you got a harpoon
let's let's aim at him and you got him
man he's out game over
is that it oh he's limping away let's
get him let's get if you can boost with
the X button that's going yeah that's
right I keep forgetting about that's
gonna let you catch up to him and a
boost regenerate so I don't need to
worry about yeah and it doesn't spend
fuel either it spins nitrous so you
don't have to worry about losing fuel
but yet I then I can't Huff the nitrous
to make myself laugh later what
murder there's so much to talk about
this sort of approaching Jesus what's
happening there's storms in this game I
love the storms in this game and they're
completely procedural they're completely
random oh my god
so I'm glad that we encountered one
let's see if you can take this guy out
before you're in the grip he's in here
we go let's check him out
chumbucket I think grew up in Texas
where I grew up because this is there we
go let's ran the bat if you ran the back
yeah
oh no the store Oh God ah so oh we got
to kill this dude it's still going still
there yeah this is insane
so something I want to encourage you to
do before you get too far in cuz cuz you
take you're gonna take damage in the
store oh we will
so come to a come to a complete halt oh
man we're gonna lose the guy and tap
yeah always a guy don't worry man you're
gonna find more guys oh my god the storm
is crazy all right we're gonna complete
home let's hit up on the d-pad Oh Chuck
Oh Jim's gonna heal our car he's gonna
climb out in the middle of the storm all
this debris that's blowing around in the
storm that's uh that's coming from camps
in the wasteland that's not what God
dudes that you've taken out so your
magnum opus if you allow Chum he'll
always uh he'll take care of it for you
he'll climb to the front he'll wrench on
it
and he'll get you back to two fully
functioning condition and there's more
than one kind of storm right yeah this
is a sandstorm but there's electrical
storms oh my god this is insane
the the gameplay benefit of the storms
is there's giant loot crate's
okay scrap they're called mother lutes
mother loot mother loot is blown around
in the storm and sort of the risk reward
is if you stay out in the storm it is
probably gonna kill you oh my god but
you can locate you actually really close
to a mother Lew you can see them where
is it on the map you've got those kind
of different looking those hands that
are surrounded by the flashy looking oh
yeah those are mother laughs mother Lu
let's go get a mother Luke ray and scrap
you're not scrap is not provided in
abundance in this game you
dismantle enemy camps you have to take
care of enemies
she flood the biggest drops of scrap
you'll find our in these storms so
storms are a good thing oh my god this
is crazy
and they're so a couple different things
you can do in a storm you can hide
because when someone's asking is a kid a
giant piece of debris knocked chumbucket
offer its chumbucket
he's gonna hang on right nobody's gonna
hang on he's thank god he's a pretty
nice Chum buckets gonna be fine don't
worry he's a pretty spry dude he can he
can duck and dodge oh we found the outer
graves that sounds like a cool bar but
if you outer graves love it love it good
plug barn bar named good gastro pub
gastro yeah with maggots yeah exactly
yeah let's get a man you wanna go eat
some maggots to the outer graves they're
really doing some interesting things
with which maggot
yeah oh here we go wait here's the giant
lootcrate oh yeah I'm so target it with
your harpoon okay because you're gonna
need to drag it out of that uh now just
drive away and pull it out of the pull
it out of that geometry that it's need
to bail you want to bail out
heyo get out yeah get out and then go
nice dismount hell yeah open it up open
it up we're in the storm dude let's get
back in the car so one hundred one
hundred scrap that's more scrap and
you'll typically get yeah oh you're in
the back oh look at this where you have
a sniper rifle in the bag my god this is
awesome
oh wait storms over and you can up it
and you can actually drive you can have
Chum drive you around while you're
sniping in the back so that's what I was
talking about with oh that's gonna be
the mobile for mobile fortress man wait
there's more wait when should I get this
scrap - I think you oughta so I guys I'm
sorry I can't talk to you and playing
this game the same time it's way too
intense it's yeah it's a challenge it's
a loot crate
[Music]
so that's your scrap everything you do
dude there's so much happening every
time you doing the game all the upgrades
like you're just gonna be talking for 90
minutes I can do it you can do it I
believe in you Daniel all all so all the
upgrades in the game everything you do
to the magnum opus everything you do to
max you can upgrade Max's combat
abilities yeah his leather pants oh hell
yeah his leather jacket awesome that's
all gonna require scrap so scrap is a
pretty sought-after resource you
definitely want to get as much as you
can get that paper to this storm is
intense right now and if you have a if
you run into an enemy camp or if you're
doing combat hand-to-hand combat yeah
that debris that's flying around is
gonna be knocking enemies over or crazy
so it kind of helps the source kind of
help they can't they're gonna die they
weren't hurt oh yeah they're gonna hurt
you too oh my god this is insane all
right so we can try to get another loop
but God part of the fun of this game is
just how much procedural insanity is
being thrown your way I didn't get my
procedural you mean to kill random
random yeah we're all this crap just
blowing around and you're all this
debris you're not gonna see the exact
same encounter happen you know ever oh
yes my cars take me like a ton of damage
yeah the cars gonna take damage so a
couple a couple interesting things you
can do if you you know you're a you and
you encounter these storms when you're
playing the game at home yeah you either
want to stay out for that risk reward of
locating scrap or you want to take
solace in a stronghold well okay so we
can actually take shelter at the
beginning of the game you were in jeeps
stronghold we saw a gaseous stronghold
on the map you can go take shelter in
those strongholds or if you've taken
over an enemy camp and you'll see enemy
camps all over the map you can take over
an enemy camps and populate it with
Allied forces oh that's cool and that's
gonna give you shelter from those storms
as well awesome
what's this here this is a this is just
a loot location oh nice so if we get out
we're gonna be able to find scrap
probably food most likely we'll find
some combat some bad guys hey yeah hey
fellas howdy everybody so here's a
here's a good chance to
nice carry dude oh yeah you got what do
you got bring it so if I hit a bunch of
dudes in a row tell me about the fury
meter oh yeah so you've got uh you've
got a combo meter that's building up on
the on the top right that piece of HUD
that you see over there that's your fury
meter and if you can keep your chain
going for long enough that's gonna
activate fury mode with fury active
you're gonna deal more damage you're
gonna have wider parry windows it's
gonna help you manage a moment-to-moment
combat a little better because combat in
Mad Max it's definitely about crowd
control you're gonna be fighting a lot
of dudes at the same time and they're
not gonna be waiting to take a swing at
you like they wouldn't come film from
this from the 70s they're all gonna be
getting in the melee at the same time so
Fury's gonna help you manage that combat
a little better and one of the things I
was when I was play before it kinda
reminds me the comment mine's me in the
best way of one of my other favorite
games Batman I'd like the flow combat is
so fun and this is you have the same
kind of parry situation like I just in
Batman and I think in this game I just
OH let's throw it you pop it in the air
to it so pick it back up
yeah and throw it again and then tap
that tap Circle again when it's in the
air okay let's do this away from my car
maybe maybe here we go let's just so
throw it and then tap circle again yeah
[Music]
excellent shooting there Tex mission oh
but I seem like it's really great like I
just love wandering around just beating
people up cuz combats so fun I do too
it's great it's very satisfied yeah and
like you said I mean there's there's
there's a nod to Arkham in the sense
that we let the player do a whole lot
was very little yeah so you don't need
to be you know doing a lot of finger
acrobatics right with the controller
enables it in order to do a whole lot we
we really let the player we've given
them the tools to manage all the the
madness and it is really cool to like
the Veeck I'd love you guys do with the
vehicle combat it's something like I
haven't actually ever seen before I mean
it's just when you're driving and this
is why my head is full of bees today the
guys
I don't know if you guys can tell but
like when I'm gonna and I'm gonna try to
find this cowboy here so you can really
see a lot of put it's so insane like
there's a thousand things going up oh
here we go I'm gonna hit this guy
head-on ah so that's just a random war
party these are just the dudes this oh
this isn't even a cowboy these are just
dudes that are out - they're out for
blood
let's pull them out that was awesome
through the windshield oh man that is
awesome
I can't possibly tell you how much time
I spent playing this game but I still
love yanking dudes out of their vehicle
with my harpoon whoo Oh lose a tire
there pal now now bail out of the
vehicle cuz that guy's got
he's got no means to-- yeah let's beat
him up let's go beat him up let's go
let's go punch him in the face about
waiting to punch someone in the brains
all day oh oh you're all tricky yeah
that's a electric what do you think
about that oh oh yeah I want to go see
your dentist there pal he can take his
whip if you want also let's take his
whip yeah I mean that one has a it's
missing a tire but I just want to point
out that you call yeah we can't drive
this thing what are you talking about
Danny I pulled the desire off why would
I want to drive it let's pop let's pop
that gas oh good idea
let's just let's aim at it and get rid
of this oh that's a good idea alright
let me good a little kids when you're
shooting gas tanks of shotguns and Mad
Max you want to step get about 10 feet
away safety first safety first kids
safety first
whoo there we go
and the reason why now you got scrap you
got this oh yeah you're right but what
am i doing
you can turn I mean you can if it's made
of metal you can you can get that metal
that's cool and one thing too is now if
I take this enemies car then I can well
I can like be disguised and go into
their hideouts is different can be
undetected by yeah when you head into an
enemy camp you'll be detected by see now
you're detected by certain factions but
you can hide from others oh I see it or
you can take it back to a stronghold add
it to your collection and that lets you
take it into races whoa that's cool so
there are death races all around the
world
I do love death races we all do I do
love a good death race or as I call it
my morning commute and there's yeah at
4:00 or 5:00 you drive all over the 405
the wasteland
this is very similar to my morning
commute situation exactly I think we can
all relate man exactly
ah Bert Bert oh yeah I got it
Virgina moon share I think it's French
all right here we go
I'm gonna I really want to take apart a
cowboy because I want to get a new hood
orange so let's go back to let's go back
to our map real quick and make sure
we're headed in the right direction to
find that red try we got close to it so
if you just if you just stay on the the
path that you're on you're gonna come
across those all this tired those tire
marks that are gonna indicate a convoy
yeah and a couple things a couple
reasons why you want to participate in a
convoy you see that you've got a hood
ornament mounted on the rear bumper of
your vehicle yeah those give you
different aside from just looking
totally kick-ass yeah which it does
those are going to ghetto cow skull it's
a little 90s there's a little light go
you got in the front you got some things
in front my god what am i rocking up
here did you say Oh God oh no oh jeez
Doberman really gotta watch the road
gotta watch the road team loser
suggested down here oh man did you say
that that was very Damn Yankees yeah
very Tim yeah all right here we go let's
get back up was that was that Ted Nugent
super go whoops what yeah oh yeah super
goo cool wait no wait a second should I
help it I'm not helping these guys you
can help these guys let's help them I
got a full canteen here hey guys yo hey
yo yo hey hey your boys got ya your boys
got some water here there we go
oh you're gonna you gonna use some
chapstick there man yeah that's bad uh
or a straw oh you just put his put his
mouth like your lips on my canteen
that's disgusting ah so I thought you
might have asked like why would you why
would you help these guys any why would
I help these guys
well you just completed an objective by
helping out those Wanderers and oh dude
there's your there's your convoy leader
Dario let's do it that's the one you
detected earlier so now he shows up on
your oh I'm gonna kill the crap out of
this dude it's gonna be awesome
so you get ya the game map is massive
rubber ducky it's awesome it also looks
like a giant brain by the way does this
look like a giant brain does kinda it's
awesome everything in this game is
creepy in the best way that's what I
love about Matt Matt
I love my favorite Mad Max en trope is
baby dolls yeah yeah I know what I mean
there's no shortage of plastic doll
components right they're gonna last
forever they're made out of plastic yeah
they'll be around for 10,000 years plus
I got my harpoon at the ready well you
know what I'm gonna do here I'm gonna
use the old Thunder poon tell us what a
thunder poon is Oh Thunder poon is and
you've got a good supply of them you can
you can take out vehicles with the
magnum opus just by ramen but chumbucket
can also Huck these these explosives of
Spears at vehicles and that's your most
devastating weapon in the magnum opus
when it comes to vehicle combat but the
only a short supply although I have a
ton of them they're in short supply hook
me up but like like everything else in
Mad Max you can upgrade those so you can
oh that was bad sorry Magnum but you
you're never really like I like that you
just shorten it to Magna yeah your name
my kid magnum opus blares ah okay that's
a really good name do ya well except for
the last part but yeah I'm saddled with
that last name so no I can do there but
I think I think you're compensating you
get well definitely yeah
overcompensating all right let's see
here I think is enough you go this way
yeah I think he was right behind you but
you can catch up you can always get your
booster ooh hey what's up fan of Jay oh
man all right let's see here ah just now
here's the here's just a question do you
think jump bucket gets upset when I
wreck the car do you think he's happy
because then he gets to fix it again
well I think yeah probably the ladder
the ladder he's happy he's acting more
do you it gives him something to do you
know if you love your job you never work
a day in your life I don't care if
you're in the wasteland or if you're
working in an office
yeah well also Chuck really likes to see
you uh floor the floor the [ __ ] yeah he
gets pretty excited when you fly it off
of a cliff or or he's about to get real
excited then here we go cuz I feel like
there's a lot of cliff jump it about
that when you get airborne that you'll
he's having a good time man he's he just
likes to see that Max's and
the toys toys that he's giving him he
likes to see you uh what did he think
what do you think your heart poonam
start a little harpoon here's what I
meant wheel off do perfect okay we got
Jesus but you're fine you're fine let's
go let's go sorry Chum you're welcome
Chum either one you're never really in a
deficit with the magnum opus you've got
plenty of plenty of tools to catch up so
yeah I'm gonna tell you what I'm going
to use right now the old Thunder pin get
back in this game you just like saying
thunder I do I do it's terrible I do too
so I would made my second kid Thunder
booms Thunder booms he's probably gonna
be pretty teased at school or he's gonna
be the king of that school yeah what or
he's got he's got a great stage name
look we're just going by T food yeah
it's he proven exactly here we go
so you're doing what I would do you
would you're saving the resources for
the you're using your using your heavy
explosives on the convoy and then ya
Yankees tire now I'm noticing the Sun
appears to be setting is there a 24-hour
there is a day/night cycle sterner room
yep oh you know what let me get my
shotgun out cut yeah because this guy
seems like he's loaded with fuel yeah or
guzzoline as chumbucket calls out of my
way
stop trying oh he's got the old tire
grinders it dude oh now it's on you know
what now you're gonna get a shotgun to
the face before I was just gonna harpoon
yet and maybe vice no and this is
personal let's get it and you can't you
can't do that you can drive up you can
get real close and you can target his
face oh it's gonna be grand you can pop
him in the face with a shotgun
oh it's exposed oh sorry
wait I'm not sorry hey man they they
knew the risk inherent in crossing that
road boom yeah another one so we'll next
thing you guys next along I was gonna
take him down what are you gonna do I
don't know what should I do
I don't know man you can Ram him you
can't it seems like that shotguns
working pretty well
- gimme Oh oh jeez oh that's gonna
that's gonna leave a mark
getting lightheaded ever gonna leave a
mark it's gonna leave a mark I'll tell
you something
lb I was gonna get lightheaded the guy I
shoot in the head with the shock -
shotgun flame pipes harpoon Elantra
pilots flame pipe or punch him with the
fist of your car what are you gonna do
man what are we gonna do a flame Oh God
first of all I'm gonna run over all
those rocks and then I'm gonna get back
on the road sorry whose something
happened oh well I mean wait what
happened that I mean friendly fire is on
so any number of things could have
happened to him he could have he could
have run into another war party that
took him out he could wait he's up there
though art-lete isn't he up there
well that's them that's the leader oh we
don't care about that guy we care but we
want this who don't want the leader yeah
here we go here we go so let me tell you
all the cool things are gonna happen
easy to pick him out of the desert when
he's asked us out of fire oh but he's
gonna hit you too with it with all the
way you're right you're right it looks
like somebody a little too much Taco
Bell oh I'm gonna I'm gonna follow at a
leisurely pace through this Canyon all
right so what do we think I want to see
you get what do we think clothes and
flame pipe a meritless flame pipe it
anything you do is gonna go he's hanging
on by a thread though the world is your
last thread let's burn it come on give
me the boost chumbucket you got it you
got it there we go all right fire
scarecrow no no no God son just get
ahead of him come on Magnum no damn it
ah you know chump ugh and I don't want
to rip on you pal but your weights
really throw it off my handle in here so
you know what you could do you could
change you could change the build of the
magnum opus cuz it looks like you're a
little I'm a little time little heavy
drink a little acid Yarmuth look at this
beautiful sunset though let's just I
know let's take a minute for a mire I'll
do that hurts yeah that hurt hurt that
was bad that was bad second moment from
the race - just admire the sunset it's
so beaut
let's go let's go and Oh God
let's thunder Poona man let's play it's
a no no no oh no it's alright alright
help me out chummy
good opportune
talk about a chum bucket so Chum buckets
got your back man yeah look at him look
at this boy hello he's got to see his
dermatologist that's there's some moles
on the back of his okay that's the those
that could be precancerous I'm worried
about it look at that no could be that's
that's not good he's got a moisturize
that guy's got a moist
wank driver I'm sorry I know I suck I'm
sorry I'm sorry but you're giving me you
wanted to give Chum an opportunity to do
what he loves thank you that's very nice
of you to say I think I was just a
terrible driver nursed it back to full
health as we take off we'll see Chum
scurry back to his uh
scurry scurry back all right here we go
I'm kidding I get a Kevin takes me an
hour and a half I'm gonna kill this the
cowboy driver I got time man actually
mine it actually might take me an hour
now now one thing is if I don't kill the
Commodore right away more guys are gonna
come right oh here's this guy well I
mean he's he's at your mercy right now
because it saves your progression so
you'll be able to catch up with him and
deal with them so he's still gonna be
hurtin but he might have more guys with
him he could pick up more guys they'll
see he'll still be hurtin for certain is
that his uh man I was driving so much
better before the lives through I swear
to God I was driving so much better
yeah when there's an audience it's a
little nerve-racking okay into dust
cloud man you're gonna be able to the
left which is that the dust cloud that's
your desk AHA dust but here we go I do
the environmental cues are really cool
in this game right he didn't make it far
in his injured state oh dude come on
Blair nah dude spinning your way you're
looking for short time ago yeah I know
you're right I need this I need to stay
on the road I'm trying to go fancy with
it all right here we go roads are
suggested bro yeah we're going we don't
need roads well we kind of need roads I
mean can't just here we go
let's do you know no more messing around
was just under the under pronoun weird
dude what is up I was doing way better
for the record I know no one in the chat
please how can you not drive straight I
know I'm sorry I'm quivering with the
excitement of about the impending death
that I'm about to deal on this guy's
face ok so cool
he didn't pick up any more dudes all
right no more dudes just D dude alright
I've selected the Thunder poon yeah
you'll make sure work of them with with
uh I just keep with the old teachers
love saying T P come on T poon seafood
alert I wish I knew a t-pain song for
the team food and kill I'm about to do
here we go just auto-tune the way you're
talking boom got him Oh didn't kill him
there we go two more you're like I hope
he doesn't really have a car yeah I
don't drive in real life guys everyone
should know that I don't want to shoot
that guy
so I think he's armored I don't I you
can have here I'm gonna pull off a wheel
you can remove but you can remove the
panel's of his are more tuned that's
gonna give you a direct shot to those
gas tanks with the with the shotgun or
just steering right him yeah there we go
there we go
oh yeah head on bro head on
yeah that'll work uh-oh let's pull him
out of the car get him
I can't he's armored it get it get it
yeah so not so that was awesome you get
so you got him but you still gotta take
out his vehicle so anything you do is
gonna take it out what do you think
shotgun no no let's Tipu I would get I
would get out shoot oh and walk away ooh
that's a good you know it's great but
don't look at the explosion altitude
it's such a greater than Nic Cage you
mean let's Nick Cage it yeah hey Nick
can't trust you in the back what do you
think anything's gonna do it man here we
go here we go
guys get ready for a sweet michael bay
shot over the shoulder yeah and now we
just walk away what's up don't even look
don't even look bro name is max so
loading floor you got scrap he's got a
hood oh yeah oh wait we got to go over
there we gotta get the hood ornament
there it is
I normally don't approach flaming
vehicles but when it comes to getting
cool cool hood ornament look at that
pretty dope that is great look how big
that is
I'm gonna get like a whole giant burrito
yeah
don't you be put in the front of the
back ah either so you've got tools in
the back let's do the back cuz we'll see
so we'll see the fruits of your labor as
we drive around if you put it on the
back yeah exactly plus I'm tired of look
at that cow skull let everybody know who
approaches you from behind that tee poon
Blair yeah
he's patrolling the wasteland amrite TSP
so you got scrap can't get away so you
got a hood ornament there are there it
is it's so pretty it's party and its own
party it also gives you a passive bonus
so you either oh cool
you're either dealing more damage or
you're taking more damage whoa that's
your awesome yeah you're usually more
outfitted for the wasteland now and you
lower the threat in the territory
awesome the wait no what does that do so
ever every territory starts at 5 right
perfect segue awesome every territory
starts at a threat level of 5 and
everything you do in the territory from
taking out
taking out snipers taking out war
parties convoy leaders securing enemy
camps okay all of those things are gonna
lower the threat and the lower the
threat gets the more unlocks you're
going to be able to get got it for the
magnum opus for max awesome you see that
you're constantly completing objectives
those are the meters that Phil at the
top of the screen yeah everything you do
in the wasteland is is filling some kind
of meter so moment to moment you're just
gonna be constantly bombarded with all
this positive feedback that's letting
you know the way ton to do in the ski
the wasteland Wanderers that you gave
water to earlier that was an objective
that you completed and by completing
objectives not only do you get scrapped
but you're getting Griffi tokens and
those are who's griffa Griffi if we zoom
into the map he's probably on here
somewhere I think he's down over here
somewhere we might have to zoom out a
little bit to see his icon he looks like
a little ghost on the map that's
hilarious
but he's our he's kind of like our
merchant that if we go to Ghana can
spend tokens to upgrade Max's of core
abilities oh that's awesome
so his combat abilities oh that's and
that's how we actually level up Mack
sister Griffin right Scottish so he's uh
there he is right there you see that
little that guy right there guy right
here
that's griffa he's this super weird
mystic dude maybe can we go see Griffin
let's go man let's go see Griffin and
then maybe let's try a mission yeah we
can do he'll like the old pink I'm
mission heading into an enemy yeah
that's gonna be a great what is that
chance to see some yeah some like death
some death there's death everywhere in
this game you have to look for it
there's death booms right here yeah the
tire is my favorite just leave me alone
tactic yeah exactly
you don't want to deal with Donnie
they're gonna see you Oh how's that face
not enough fists in it burn udom chummy
he's all helping us out what
while I'm beating the crap out of
somebody chummy selling sticks in the
vehicle yeah we're such a good team he
knows how Manmeet Chum he knows his room
coming at TBS this fall max and Chuck
jump is that they move into apartment
together
like they work at a they work at a bagel
shop and they get on each other's nerves
but you know what they really yeah I li
due respect to Sean buck did you not do
the dishes again
I'm sorry Steve I'm sorry I fixed up the
car I don't own a car
laughter cue applause did you eat my
mangas yeah did you eat my baguette over
in the corner chump
look maggots chumbucket sorry same shoe
laughter exactly
hilarious it's it writes its executives
that's a free idea right self free idea
there we go
wait what were we doing already Griffin
so Griffin that's right but we got a
turn on it so if we want to upgrade
Max's like oh wait what's this thing
over here is this the what is this big
thing scarecrow let's get close and
looking at at first because it's it's
gnarly it is I mean one of these from my
apartment I think yeah
look at I'd be so cool people come over
like dude I love your giant scarecrow
bro I'm like yeah it's a fire hazard
look yeah I brought a home from Burning
Man yeah I got it for bro it's a it's
assembled of scrap and human bodies
awesome oh yeah look at this look at all
the dead bodies you know if we destroy
it
what do you think happens who move
threat lever lowered threat level low or
not that's right pay attention I paid to
scrap I was a great high five well you
know you know the secret for high five
what I note look at the elbow
oh yeah there we go I love it miss I
love it I'm doing I'm doing goals this
summer to come down lower the tables
like it doesn't like the tingles should
we share our harpoon at this thing we
should always shoot our harpoon and
everything great I love that answer
Drive baby drive right off that cliff oh
yeah let's pull around drive right off
the cliff want to see it though come
down me too oh yeah oh man so there we
go
threat down we got some scrap now we can
Ram it we can hit it with a with some
tea poon whoo or you can harpoon it
there's there's all kinds of cool things
except you guys you live how you want to
live in the wasteland yeah baby you do
your own thing
wait maybe we should maybe we should
upgrade our car a little bit we got some
extra scrap let's do it what do you guys
think maybe hand what about handling hey
I'm doing terrible adult and handling is
one of the few things that I think is
like you always want more handling right
you always want to be able to drive a
little better everything else is really
about treads
creating the vehicle that you want and
playing the way you want but we always
want to handle this is gonna hit this is
gonna help our handling right here let's
get these it's gonna I mean it's still
do agree there is drift yeah so
basically if you press down the controls
are right triggers gas a hardened left
is left is brake right if you hold it
down it's hand brakes that's right yeah
yeah I'm just not doing it but yes there
is drift
we gotta have drift in the wasteland
baby if that fast to furious Tokyo Drift
style but you know post-apocalyptic so
it's nighttime now Oh different
different wasteland gangs will come out
depending on that's cool day/night cycle
so while some some go to hide you're
gonna run into other gangs like the
buzzards ooh
they come out at night mostly and they
have way more spikes than the other guys
we can which you can get to you can get
spikes for the opus and if dudes try to
they got spikes on spikes on spikes but
yeah you can put spikes on your spikes
and if if an enemy tries to board you
like jump on your vehicle in the middle
of driving through the wasteland they'll
get impaled awesome you can get out of
your car and do combat and throw dudes
into the spikes on your vehicle so you
can use it as like I said man it's a
mobile fortress let's see here wait I
just want to how about some fire
scarecrow Lee what's that enemies sat
again once you lower the threat level
well they well there are still roving
gangs that come in yeah but there won't
be it won't be as dangerous so so well
like these guys right here that's just a
randomly generated war party that's uh
it's coming to come in to mess with you
and those guys will still be around just
want to just run him over a few more
times yeah let's just make sure he's
dead finish the job
jelly all right let's go see grip oh
yeah yeah there's still going to be war
parties that are roaming around but the
war the camps they'd have enemies those
of them those will be dealt with and the
benefit of taking over a camp is they're
gonna be constantly providing you'll see
them populate with allies and those
allies are working to generate scrap for
max they'll come through you can upgrade
the any stronghold as well so you can
fill it with allies that are gonna
follow you around in the wasteland and
collect the scrap that you're leaving in
your wake oh that's awesome
they really just help you like they
really empower you to get where you want
to go kind of remember that cave for let
for the next storm all right here we go
Griffi so if you were driving around in
the wasteland right now and you weren't
sure where you were going you could look
to that plume of smoke in the in the
distance yeah that's a probably an enemy
camp do you think Chum buckets cold no
it's got the desert camo yeah you know
what I'm saying he's riding in the back
all that wind I think the South we're
assured of of helping max kill dudes
yeah it's probably the radiation even
more that too man yeah he's got like a
permanent sunburn basically here we go
all right
tell me I'll be right back all right he
knows he knows as well be right back
chomp stir he's gonna wrench your right
back Jimmy rip Chum Chum arewe Chum Chum
oh here we go
no we don't know if Griff is real or if
he's just a part of our imagination
right cuz we might be queer crazy it's
Mad Max it's not well-adjusted
emotionally healthy max yeah whoa dude
what is up this is kind of creepy yeah
but you're right man we don't know we
don't know where this guy is I don't
know if he's in the wasteland are in our
Cup ezza Big Sur I've got an extra
yeah random war party driving by is it
possible to show where you go to upgrade
the people to gather the scrap for you
if possible thank you in advance scruffs
dad yeah we're gonna head to and I think
we're gonna try to head to an enemy
stronghold or allied stronghold okay and
that's where you can do all the
upgrading you can collect there's all
kinds of different stuff to collect and
when you do when you deliver pieces of
let's talk about this first okay cool so
this is this is where you upgrade Max's
legend his health his ability to remain
in fury mode longer Wow cool consume
less fuel get more from the food he
consumes get more from the water that he
collects everything that so what should
we do here maybe maybe it maximum health
yeah
longevity is always good longevity is
always you've got 10 coins to spend
those are that you get in those coins
from driving around completing
objectives leveling max up let's do this
we haven't I don't use a lot of melee
weapons I like so I like to do the water
waters get sense and I like to do the
one above that judgment so that's an
animal what's that that's gonna increase
Max's legend and the more that you
increase his legends the more unlocks
from max are available goddess so
increasing his ammunition capacity his
gauntlets that he wears on his on his
wrists those all come from just raising
his legend got it cool all right and
let's do let's do food a little fork in
the and the Plus metabolism so a couple
though next time you find food it's
gonna maggots or dog food love it either
way I'm not picky I'm not a picky eater
this pie a little better you Mazda's not
carbs slices not carbs you know yeah I
mean no carbs in the way so cars the way
said alright let's go see a stronghold
now let's do this mission quick word
Griff ago oh my god where is he did is
he elsewhere in the wasteland Noah knows
you know brain no one knows man he's
like yeah it's a very Tyler Durden esque
spoilers for a movie came out in 93 what
happens if max does it eat or drink
enough he dies uh yeah he's his health
is it's not like it's constantly waning
he doesn't have to man
that in the wasteland that's right it
but he doesn't have he doesn't have like
Auto region health so as he comes out of
combat he's gonna need to he's gonna
manage health that way that's a pretty
big set piece I know that's something
over there yeah but a customization on
Macs someone wants to see let's do it
so for that there we go this is the
custom Asian iMac so you get the knuckle
dusters so this is uh more damage or
damage jacket armor and we can we can we
can go into these two so we can get
there's all kinds of stuff here so you
should definitely get these knuckle
dusters so what do I want here oh this
these are here the jaw the jaw hammers
jaw hammers every new yeah and you'll be
able to see like everything is you got a
lot of scrap let's buy some stuff let's
buy some stuff man so that that changed
what's on his wrists there and that's
like I got crazy assembly of nuts and
bolts that he wears on his hands this is
obviously armor here so we got patrol
leather tank leather I love upgrading
the jacket just cuz uh I love a good
leather jacket and Max has some good
ones hell yeah
shank leather let me got wrist armor you
don't want to get carpal tunnel that's
from when max types yes is to protect
against the bad typing yeah yeah we got
roll bar guard oh and cRIO so this is
like for parries and stuff increases
your parry window that's great creases
damage let's get the grinder guard there
you go you can see he just starts to
look more gnarly he's just a cat action
of ammo belt so more ammo
you've got the best one you can have
right now but you can see uh the next
ones are available from leveling up his
legend and this is how we do we're
eventually gonna hit when we hit legend
rank we had road warriors the top one
that you've got a long way to go there's
five there's ten levels to each level so
you've got a dude hey this is the most
important part right here the head
upgrades doesn't change doesn't change
it's just cosmetic but uh you can you
can grow a pretty sick beard oh look at
this race paint what else can we do here
the third one is my favorite oh this one
long hair and beard oh yeah that's great
let's keep it and then uh we said we
were looking at ammo but you can upgrade
the shotgun to deal significantly more
damage
let's do this this is good shotgun
upgrades three tubes scatter you know I
love my three tubes scatter and here's
where he gets really interesting for me
oh yeah
so I mean the combat is really pretty
simple to pick up and play yeah but
there's there's a lot of depth to
discover through it and here's here's
where you get to unlock all those skills
so yeah let's do the gut shot to having
uh oh yeah do you not have got shot yet
no shoulder shot yeah there it is gun
shot here we go gunshots one of the best
early game combat unlocks and that's
cool when we get into combat you're
gonna see why tools we got all the tools
here tools you can't upgrade but those
are different things that you get pretty
uh most of you get pretty early in the
game I'd say that like my favorite one
is the flare gun yeah so opus let's say
you get you get lost you can't find opus
you can fire a flare and Chum is gonna
find you in a heartbeat that's awesome
bring the car right to you if someone
wants to see the clothes here we go scab
skivvy you can throw leather will take
through the shank leather go back to the
ticket so take it off take it take it
off you go to the X and we'll show you
like oh just a quick look at the ball
and you can play through you can jump
back and forth depending on what the
mission is you can change your stuff
right if you want to but for max it's
kind of always like you wouldn't want to
yeah but but for the car you can you can
be like oh I'm gonna need I'm doing a
race I'm gonna take off my armor so I
can be fast or if you just want to show
dudes how good you're looking in the
wasteland hahaha take it off man take it
all off show them with that paleo diet
all right let's see your so let's do the
let's go to this mission let's do a
mission shall we do that yeah your story
mission is always highlighted by so
let's go up to this let's go okay you
know what we I think we could fast
travel to here right you can fast travel
to if you hit the triangle button yeah
that's gonna show you the points that
you can fast travel to granny balloons
are those are outposts that you discover
on your own okay or and that raise you
above so then you can kind of see unlock
a bunch of stuff around you right yeah
when we were looking at the map earlier
and you saw all the all the different
camps and all the different objectives
that you can travel to those are
unlocked
cuz earlier you you went up in a balloon
and you identified all the difference
it's awesome things you can do now that
looks like something huge up there let's
go over there this this looks like
something huge insane that might be gas
town so even though that's like later
game content you can always see these
these these set pieces that you're gonna
need to deal with
let's do fast travel again let's hit the
triangle button okay oh shoot could
should we try it fast travel up here
yeah let's get closer
here we go oh so you can't go you can't
go there let's just drive there you
haven't unlocked that outpost you know
crazy alright oh so I guess I can't do
the pink eye thing but we can we can
highlight we can highlight them the
story mission icon yeah oh there we go I
know that'll show us where we're going
on the road dawn in the desert I mean I
must say like this is it's a very very
pretty game yeah and I think the more
that the more that's going on at any
point in time the just the prettier
looks absolutely like you saw the storm
earlier I was insane when there's when
there's a war party following you and
there's a lightning storm yeah and stuff
is exploding yeah the lightning storm is
crazy so we really like the more
cylinders that are firing the the more
appealing it is to look at all right
here we go it's it a little drifting
I'm terrible drifting my fingers have
two modes press as hard as possible and
don't press anything that's okay man you
can you can do that in the wasteland
wait a second I wonder say there's a lot
of good Instagram sunset yeah if they
had Instagram in this sewage it kill
selfie mode this is selfie let me see it
can I go after Annie I mean you can see
that even though it's the wasteland and
everything's destroyed
you're constantly seeing new stuff you
should totally you're seeing these new
outposts assembled from from junk and
scrap that that the wasteland that
scrotus and his boys have built
scrote old scrote scrote scre out and
his boys there we go I do love to like
it looks blurry in the back it's so
great in might we got to go get pinkeye
well we don't have to bracket again -
yeah yeah I'm gonna get pinkeye we're
even though it's the wasteland we we
wash our hands
yeah sullied you bet hygienic yeah
no it's the wasteland you know you don't
you don't stay alive for long if you
you're not practicing clinically I'm a
man chumps got some bad teeth that guys
gotta go see somebody
so I'll set you up before you get to two
pink guys yeah so tell it tell us kind
of what the story is what's happening
here though well Pete guys stronghold is
being rated right now okay and like I
said earlier these aren't really your
allies there's there's sort of a shaky
alliance pink guys not really are allied
not really our ally but she's got what
we need in particular she can help us
unlock some some great upgrades for the
magnum opus so we're gonna lend a hand
cool it gives only cuz it's gonna help
us only because it's gonna help us cuz
that's how we roll I love that beard
that's so great I love the beer - dude
it's not enough beards and games oh
chumbucket can he be replaced can he die
can we upgrade mr. chum you can upgrade
Chum Bucket no no one yes yeah no no no
yes yeah you can you can check you can
he's hidden tools throughout the
wasteland oh cool so there are a bunch
of shot there's tons of side mission
this game that unlock different
different narrative perspectives or for
chumbucket for example you can go find
these tools that he's hidden yeah and
you can equip those to chumbucket and
that's gonna help him repair the opus
way faster got it got it so yeah so he
can be you can you can upgrade him as a
mechanic to help you survive longer so
you know your car is it takes last time
cuz every every moment you're sitting
there you're sitting duck yep
all right here we go baby let's let's
get in there so we got it first we got
to destroy this patrol party out here
right yeah alrighty what's your pro at
cuz you took out a convoy earlier so and
I have to say I think just generally
when you guys play this game I've found
that yet you never really want to stop
driving if you could just keep driving
the combats way because when you as soon
as you stop you're just like a sitting
duck
it's a Connecticut game first yeah yeah
Marinette again forward momentum at all
times alright make sure work of these
dudes give me the yield Sidewinders
yeah I still want to come up yeah that's
right step up do you see what happens
you can upgrade those two though the
flame pipes have three different tiers
whoo by the time you get to the the
final tier they're just devastating
yeah and when you and everything works
together so we looked at your legend
already and there was an ability to
consume burn there we go
got him wait present all right now we're
gonna get all your dudes yeah okay that
guy's just standing on his car it's just
all right so now we gotta get the we got
to get these catapults right yeah
catapults are armored so so they're
lobbing they're lobbing explosives @p
guys stronghold so you're gonna need to
tear off the armor brush you're gonna
need a shinning X button [ __ ] him Hey oh
yeah
ships are let's jump oh yeah dude that's
my favorite Oh oh my god do these jaw
hammers are sweet oh damn it see you
have a oh yeah I'm getting bite yeah
titty right now if you can nail a
perfect parry if you can grab that parry
right in the perfect moment and then
attack max has crazy wrestling moves you
don't need that don't man oh man cuz you
got jaw hammers sauce
do those John Hamre is I'm not kidding
are like weapons of opportunity
everywhere oh yeah oh you got this thing
pick these weapons up whoo alright so
soup oh wait we gotta get back in the
car to pull the thing off oh yeah
so we want to take the armor off of
these catapults so we can get to the the
meaty juicy insides of these vehicles
and destroy them yank all right I'm
gonna hit it with a thunder pin how do
we feel about that I feel good about
that man oh yeah one day okay you got
two more here we go boom
see what I'm talking about man - breathe
- yeah
average look at all
oh yeah dude it's so great I love fire
Oh what's up now baby come on over here
what do you got no no it's Perry let's
get in with the Oh gunshot oh yeah oh
that's it yeah we got the gut shot so
next time got shot or ooh it's just a
circle tap when you're really close to
an enemy awesome
oh I'm gonna get shot the heck out of
that all right let's see your weight I
got it you haven't seen the gut shot
right yeah no no you in for a treat
you're very excited very excited about
the gut shot all right here we go pull
this off oh no I wasted the Thunder boo
what's that these are the best game to
breathe of everything yeah this game
debris is on point shortage of debris no
shortage of debris all right now you
know what sometimes I like to get a
little personal get up close and
personal with it oh wait why did you
leave uh why'd you leave all these uh
what are these fun what are these
thunder boots what are these yeah those
are thunder sticks the ones you can get
on foot nicely done dear Michael Bay
style nicely boom look at that look at
all the debris flying at the at the
camera that's great it would be
hilarious by the way if like I walk try
to walk away all cool and just like got
mail yeah hid in the back of debris it
can happen yeah that's what I get karma
can't be too cool oops oops don't sorry
Chum my bad
excuse me pardon me coming through all
right here we go one more
I would love to see a gunshot all right
I'd love to see if you get your hands on
one of those thunder sticks and put it
in over it oh you got a reload
damn Oh perfect
oh yeah come at me bro
oh oh oh Jesus
sorry that's the way though that was so
brutal I had to look away Oh Dan broken
thing on my head
seeking you know now I'm all hands on an
under stick for the last dude or or that
I don't need to tell you how to kill
guys oh yeah sorry yeah sorry
you just gotta tap the circle close to
this guy and or that jibs gyms
everywhere
oh wait go back I'm I'm literally
frothing at the better sorry I gotta get
my froth on you Daniel no it's okay man
this is a flop inducing it's just a
month Monday from your answer I need one
of those in my real life just like a big
yeah there's always like yes okay
surfing debris sir oh we're gonna find a
way in alright oh look I think there's a
way in right over here
bTW wait a second hold on just pick this
up real quick
anybody home yeah oh damn dude and you
can get on you can unlock finishing
moves for the for melee weapons as well
so that's another layer of combat whoo I
think we want to go in here but alright
let's turn this baby off
now this is the bet this is why I
shouldn't have chosen the big beard
because I feel like it's just gonna all
get burned off and that smells pretty
bad haha dude smell it burning hair
burning beard I would rather live in the
wasteland than have to smell burning
hair I'm not even kidding
it's my flat so my flashlight is on oh I
see it so it's attached to my finger
aha that's not like being shooting out
of his eyes like Superman no it's
actually just a flash that that's good
ah but you need it because so like
you've been driving around in the
wasteland you've spent a lot of time on
the surface of the Mad Max world but a
lot of the game happened a lot of big
poof chairs here a lot of a beanbag
chairs here this is where this is like
the Hangout is where all the kids hang
out and watch TV I mean it's a violent
world yeah but it's we want it to be
comfortably gotta become you're not
always punching and harpooning ticket
yeah although those are bad for your
back howdy fellas
nicely done man now some would say I'm
gonna get killed here those people
haven't seen me fury mode I do hit the
buttons really loud actually now getting
like self cut thanks yeah good though
man I'm getting self-conscious about my
button mashing there's different Oh get
shot Oh was I wasn't even waiting that
was great pulled it out of the perfect
on a surprise gut shot is the best gut
shot I always say great kill streak all
right let's go up here but uh I was
gonna say there's there's so much it
happens like a subterranean badass
there's a whole area of the game that's
buried there's an airport net
underground that yeah there's that
buried church fire does kind of stuff
awesome
so you're not you're not always driving
around there's plenty - there's plenty
of depths to probe oh look at this guy
fell on his spear I'm sure it was just
act up guys wait a second a lot of
accidents in this workplace
somebody needs to contact osha yeah OSHA
would have a fit for real
post-apocalyptic osha you've been
building your fury meter so next time
you get into combat it's gonna it's
gonna max out pretty quick oh my fury is
that's my secret I'm always angry
hey there pal how about one of these oh
wow talk about human debris that is fun
alright never leave me alone with some
boom sticks why don't that was your
stylist yeah I Oh points I just yeah I
just wanted you guys to know I have a
gun
warning shot come on over here come on
over here oh yeah Oh a flame get up
close and personal with it now wait is
it gonna hurt me though no you don't
even have to aim just get close okay in
circle oh my god that was awesome dude
did you see me buh-bye
peace I love that scream let's not fall
off are you hiding huh
okay so I see you you figured out you've
got a guard break so holding the square
the drop duty regrown oh cool man you
totally snap that dude's neck I played
this game with headphones for the first
time recently did you just throw up cuz
you're just like it's three gnarly man
all that all the bone crunching that you
hear the sound designer did I here we go
let's see where are we going here keep
going up that's what I say oh yeah so
here's another I mean here's another
example of even though it's a really
wide open game there's tons of there's
tons of verticality let's get some more
water what do we think about that well
actually I should drink water right
because I'm always - yeah you should
yeah you should do both used to do a
little drinkin you levelled up your
essence earlier that was the legend
screen we're looking at where you spent
Gryphon tokens yeah up on the d-pad is
gonna let you up on the depot guzzle
here perfect
probably got some weird disease cuz I
thought dude is drinking out of my
canteen I'm totally gonna get a cold now
I know alright yeah there is water we
just drank it you know it's gonna be
around here somewhere a lot of blood
because I'm gonna make it cuz I'm gonna
be empty these dudes
[Music]
so this is pinkeye in the wheelchair
right right stain gum I love it look at
ha ha he does have stank gums I mean
he's a pretty sick beard so one of the
uh there's all kinds of characters in
the game you know Mad Max is all about
yeah
having just these really vicious
larger-than-life characters so our game
is full of that and stink gum is one of
those characters that's awesome Oh
someone's asking what happens if you run
out of gas you will come to you won't
come to a complete stop you'll putter
around a little bit but we reinforce the
player pretty frequently that that's a
OH oh snap
that escalated quickly oh jeez oh
goodness meanwhile Meryl Streep over
there in the wheelchair do something
what are you doing what are you doing
help me out looks like I have to bash
the Bunsen Jude spaces in again you guys
know you're pretty good at that but you
guys know I have Jim Shaw hammers right
hey you guys I want to show you my neat
jaw hammers come on over oh dude jaw
hammer city that's hitting a man in the
back
yep good thing I got those wrist guards
it's not just for typing oh that wasn't
bad oh yeah come at me bro this guy's
just hanging back so you do have I need
it do a heavy hit for this guy if you
have ammo and you do have you do have
weapons like Chibs and N and shotguns
but you can tell it's not a run-and-gun
experience just mowing dudes down no
definitely not
Reese like ammo management's definitely
oh here you go dude
Showtime fury time
whoa
Oh whoop one for field Shaw hammers go
thunder and lightning took care of stink
gum
whoo those gums are stanky he's a stinky
bear due to mint or something I can
smell your breath from here
okay now that's that's just that
successful just except I did gotta get
your girl up on the thing that's rude
I'll text you I'll text you love you I
love you I love you so that go who's
that so that to be care about that girl
we don't really care about it she's a
character that will come across again so
guys I hope so she's she's important so
we'll get to it we'll get to know more
about her
but for now pink eye
we got a help pink eye yeah I'm a cool
dude I gave some guys water and he had
blisters on his mouth and look at the
beard look what's beard this is a hero's
beard know how long it takes me to comb
out this beard every day with like my
waist Lancome I made from human bones
damn
LK PD yes the weather changes randomly
there's storms that just are random in
this game it's awesome and there's also
a day/night cycle which is fantastic
yeah 10/10 beard I agree crazy I love it
here's a here's a good chance to show
you what's inside of a stronghold oh
cool so once we discover these we had a
storm earlier yes we can always seek
refuge in a stronghold ok good good we
can fast travel to every stronghold that
we've been to awesome we can bring enemy
vehicles back to strongholds so that we
can store them drive them around if we
want wait and if we get to take a look
around the stronghold you'll see that
there's just all kinds of different
things to upgrading you can go around
the wasteland collecting parts for
strongholds and some of the things you
can build our oil supplies so coming
back to a stronghold will instantly
refuel max awesome or you can build
scrap creep cleanup crews and those are
the guys that are gonna follow you
around and automatically collect all the
scrap from anything you destroy in the
wasteland
awesome and you'll see them you'll see
them outlined by these these shadows
that you see those indicate things that
you can you can build oh I see okay
oh I see cool yeah and if you if you
press if you probably while the game oh
this is cool so while the games turned
off they'll go and get scrap get more
scrap for you yeah
that's great subscribe I mean you need a
lot of scrap to get through this game
and get all the upgrades that you want
so it's definitely to the players
benefit to upgrade and outfit these
strongholds as much as you can you know
this place needs is a couch this are
like a rug yeah a nice area rug I think
that would only sign the place together
yeah something maybe like in an oval or
you know like with no corners I don't
even want it because this is a round
stronghold I think you want to have like
a round rug in here you know like maybe
something something a thick pile will
that too so you know you you can build
an oil well or you can go get a rug you
know just saying you know like it
wouldn't I know we're all like desperate
for survival you know it would be cool
to like make them brighten the place up
well it may be some arts on the walls I
mean we gotta live in these places right
exactly would it kill you yeah what's
the point of being alive you're not
living to put some amenities and yet
exactly exactly it's ridiculous that's
that's in the New Game+ yeah is you'll
be scavenging the wasteland looking for
a IKEA furniture the IKEA furniture DLC
and there's a there's a mini game that
you play with I you have to build it
it's a really frustrating minigame you
don't know what the meatballs are made
out of could be human could be you have
no idea the wasteland probably maggots
yeah
baguette meatballs exactly all right
let's go I think we're almost out of
time do you guys have any any more
questions for Daniel met this awesome
game oh let's go kill this guy I just
want to see just up just a tad more
death could they debris in this here we
go wow that's a kaboom bug so those guys
explode on impact
oh no wait that was bad I did that but
you know not my foot you can get those
vehicles chumbucket hook me up bro no
this dude's come oh no they're coming
back so what I would encourage you to do
hide behind your behind the geometry
that is the magnum opus they're gonna
try to ram you up but you can get you
can get close to their vehicle if they
come to a stop and just pull them right
out oh I can yeah
should I try to pull him out shut up
if you can't so this yeah yeah so you
can get that guy sure it's triangle when
you get really close all right let's try
to pull it out
oh come at me bro oh I'm getting back to
the car forget this yeah you got oh now
it's on you go look at all jump get in
the back dude it might be your last kill
what are you gonna do first I'm gonna
this guy take take his wheel off even
the odds a bit alright oh man they're
gonna get you again Oh is there gonna be
oh no I got to get out the car again is
there gonna be a PC version of the game
yeah PC Dan date with uh Xbox one and
ps4 so September first PC as well oh
yeah look at that boom I'm missing the
jaw hammers bro
never mess of the jaw hammer one more
thing I would show you if you're gonna
wrap it up yeah I would drive into the
sunset in first person oh that's a good
idea
oh yeah there's still there's first
person in this we haven't done that at
all so how do I go to first person once
you get back in the Opus double tap down
on the d-pad also how big is the map I
mean in relation to what I guess it's
massive dude here's the I mean we can
see the map again if you want to see it
it's gigantic
honestly it's endless so you see that
you see that beyond the yeah beyond the
actual game play area you can keep
driving well really you can keep driving
in the game procedurally generates
terrain for what yeah dude for that's
ads crazy avalanche man that's their
pedigree these guys oh that's awesome
these guys do open world like nobody
else so I love it so like what how big
is the map endless yeah that's I love
that I might just drive forever that's
great like let's do that let's drive I
was saying I used to you know it's like
Red Dead Redemption and like fall I
would just go and just into the lake
just wander forever so really yeah it's
cool there's no end
oh wait wait how does so double top down
yeah oh this is great and this is
horrifying it's it's totally like this
is winter clinching to come around like
this but I I
thought I was a bad driver before and
other I've always loved driving around
in first-person and games but it doesn't
feel this is crazy
it doesn't feel like anything else this
is oh do let's do it do it do it
let's go off the cliff Oh God oh my gosh
um buck you just yell pain sorry chummy
this is awesome real mad scarecrow Oh
get it bro there we go first-person
rammer Oh No forward if it's a fortified
oh this is great yeah there there's
definitely you might want to take a look
at like some of the earlier footage cuz
we we looked at all the all the upgrades
for the magnum opus you can upgrade
engine suspension exhaust the spikes on
the via everything to a degree
everything about max from the armor he
wears to the gauntlets he has on his
hands that deal out additional damage to
max himself his ability to take more
damage have more health live longer get
more from the resources and scrap that
he collects in the world and chumbucket
- you can also upgrade your mechanic
so you can he he'll be able to fix your
car faster and all that stuff there's a
there's a pretty tremendous amount of
customization available that's right uh
and somebody's asking at what point of
the Mad Max timelines this game take
place I think it it's not specified
right but there are war boys yeah it's
not it's not specified and this is just
like the movie I mean the movie you
don't really know when it takes place in
the Mad Max mythos either and this is
while it is part of the the Mad Max
world of mythos this is this is
avalanches own world so this isn't max
from the movie or max from any of the
previous movies this is a unique Max and
a unique wasteland that we haven't seen
before yes and a unique storyline so
while it takes place in the Mad Max
world it's it's completely unique yeah
alright guys I think I might try to go
just destroy this cowboy quickly is that
alright what do we think go for it dude
our last little jaunt here I just got to
see just a little more death it might be
your death might be my death but this is
what you wanted you wanted to do let's
see let's see what we can buy real quick
so oh wait oh oh there's a sniper okay
jump in the back oh yeah yeah let's get
the back triangle in the back of the no
no don't take the fuel kid don't take
the fuel can't get in the back dude no
no no get in the back how do I get in
the back on a triangle at the back of
the vehicle it's riding on the back get
in the back get in the back kid okay
you're gonna oh let me just show them
how you can get the sniper rifle in the
back and then we'll win good that's
really cool and then again like we were
talking about hop grades sniper rifle is
just one more of the things you can
upgrade in the game that's awesome
ammunition clip reload time all that
stuff you can you can continually
upgrade and progress are there any
stealth takedowns in the game or stealth
elements I think this is pretty straight
at it are there or no yeah there other
arm yeah oh my god it's not it's not an
emphasis of gameplay right right all but
there are enemies you'll encounter
that'll be have their backs towards max
and that would give you an opportunity
to sneak up oh that's awesome plus like
the shift takedowns are pretty amazing
what there is an emphasis on someone
just said blood flow yeah it's very
bloody well there is an emphasis on
being strategic when you approach an
enemy camp so all of the enemy camps
have perimeter defenses Molotov slings
which are launching explosives and max
snipers which as you can see take max
out real quick yeah so you really need
to adjust your strategy for what you're
going up with so approaching a camp from
a distance and doing recon is always to
the players benefit and that's kind of
how stealth feeds into the game got it
and it's just it's just good business
don't attack a stronghold straight on
what even idiot just like in real life
when you're attacking strongholds yeah
obviously
Bob's common sense Bob's
I love it let's see a way let's see if
there's a dude I can just kill with mine
I love the way you drive dude I know
it's crazy
I mean life means nothing to me it's the
wasteland it's a wasteland let's just go
find something to shoot Barry oh here we
go there's a sniper
oh you sniper so maybe just a percentage
oh maybe we can get out of his range
which is pretty far as you can imagine
and then holding down I would an on the
d-pad well we'll switch places with you
and Chum get the front jump there is got
him yes look at that and then you can
even drive around so if you hold on the
the right trigger oh this is awesome
yeah it's a tumble drive around don't
scratch your Chum cuz you'll just have
to fix the scratch while while you're
shooting you can is this awesome just
make sure he's all dead I'm not saying
that's a camp up on that bridge right
there so I bet bet if you zoom in you're
gonna find some subscribers up there to
deal with some is asking is there money
there's scrap is the currency in this
game yeah do money you don't need money
so I'll look at the bodies hanging good
lord you can see the little objective
markers from far away yeah that'll help
you identify what threats are actually I
see yeah and if you look to the right
you'll believe this probably see a few
more that's crazy
looks like that looks like some kind of
alright scrotus hordes here we go
alright let's kill these guys then well
what do you got boy yeah bring it
these dudes have armor so this is a wait
look all they do this is a particularly
devastating to get before boys get
murdered here then it you probably are
gonna get murdered
but I take this guy with good as you can
Chum oh there's another there's more war
boys of so many war boys
and those dudes do not lick armored I
gave up rather easy so while you can
typically just take a vehicle's tire off
or pull the driver out of the yeah out
of the driver's seat those guys are
armored so you're gonna have to whale on
them a little bit first before you can
yank tires off Chum you want to help me
here come on Chum quickly
oh so now you're close to a camp oh now
they're killing other shooting me
they're shooting and if you don't get
close enough to that camp to deal with
the snipers God Jesus and missile
launchers that are Molotov slings that
are guarding it those defenses are all
gonna become notified of your presence
and they're gonna they're gonna be way
more devastating that's what I would
have done yeah you gotta bail or do we
go back in oh no oh god no God I got you
let's go let's just take him on you know
if I get killed I get killed let's do it
in this stream do it here we go all
right switch with me tummy up on that
you think to the right yeah you're gonna
want to go cuz they're up on this bridge
up here and check out the sniper real
quick and this this particular type of
camp there are different types of camps
with different objectives oh god this is
probably your favorite kind of camp cuz
the objective is kill everybody oh that
is my fear how did you know it's a whole
weight cuz I like to kill everybody yeah
I guess there we go I share your thirst
for blood yeah guys this game comes out
September 1st
it's Mad Max it will be out for a ps4
Xbox one and PC
right I'll send it yes sir fantastic
you're gonna do man you seem to go in
he's good Oh God ah no no no no back up
ah no I think we're facing dismantling
that's bad when I'm on fire that's bad
good man you just got a bailouts
bathrobe bail bail bail bail bail drop
runaway runaway dude you did so good
this whole time it's so good how is it
the gate the game is mad max thank you
so much it's great thank you okay thank
you guys for for watching September
first go get this game it is totally
insane and fun I hope you guys had a
great time we see you guys next week on
Monday barely see you everyone
you